عمليه غير مسبوقه في تاريخ اسرائيل شهدت
تسلل مقاومين الى مناطق 48 لاول مره واسرع
عشرات
الاسرائيليين اذا كتائب القسام اعلنت بدء
عمليه طوفان الاقصى في الصباح الباكر
مطلقه الاف الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل مقاتل
القسام تمكنوا من التوغل في مستو غلاف غزه
من الجو والبر والبحر وسيطروا على عده
مستوطنات قتلوا فيها عددا كبيرا من
الاسرائيليين واسروا العشرات وشهد بعض
هؤلاء الاسرى داخل قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
بعض العربات
الاسرائيليه الله اكبر كما اظهرت مشاهد
مسجله هروبا جماعيا لمئات المستوطنين من
مناطق غلاف
غزه لكن ماذا عن الموقف في الج الجانب
الاسرائيلي صدمه وحاله من الذهول سادت
الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي تفاجا بما جرى
خاصه ان اليوم السبت هو يوم عطله رسميه
ويصادف ايضا عيد بهجه التوراه مع نهايه
عيد العرش اليهودي من جهته اعلن رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان بلاده في حاله حرب
وقال انه اوعز للجيش الاسرائيلي بالقضاء
على المقاتلين الموجودين داخل مستوطنات
غزه اما الجيش الاسرائيلي فاطلق عمليه
اسماها السيوف الحديديه قال ان الدخول
البري الى غزه قد يكون جزءا من العمليه
تطورات متسارعه اذا منذ بدء هذه العمليه
ابقوا معنا لمتابعه اخر
المستجدات